you're late dude
[Music]
today my friend and YouTube cooking star
binging with babish is here in my
restaurant to see if he could survive a
shift working on the line probably the
hardest thing would be you know
maintaining focus on each ticket we're
gonna put him through two challenges
first prep station preparing the Me's
stop got me on your board it's going to
be interesting to see him in restaurant
mode two more burgers everything is so
much faster mid service it's going to be
interesting to see him having to
multitask and respond to calls on the
line second burger station where the
stakes get higher order first ones down
been Bubba SH I don't know who it is but
he better get his man right before Jim
behind her man Oh can the internet
because you start handle the heat
let's find out bro I'm excited about
today's experiment yeah thanks for
having me have fun I know that you're
usually cooking in a controlled
environment mostly your house by myself
by yourself and nobody sees my mistakes
yeah today you're in my world you're in
my kitchen yet the usual yeah we kind of
have some certain expectations rules
line cooks are like the backbone of the
restaurant I've been to war with these
guys we were a band of brothers and
we're here every day in the trenches I'm
here for it man what are you expecting
I'm expecting to [ __ ] up a lot have you
done this before I work I plated
desserts back in like 2009 as a part
time job
in Brooklyn all right for like three
months Wow and I have waited tables back
in high school a lot of people when they
email me or when they when they meet me
on the street or whatever they say
thanks chef or good job chef and I'm
like I didn't hurt that title you know
I've never ways I've never worked an
arrest is the day I think this is
something that anybody who's interested
in cooking is really curious about like
could I make it in a kitchen
you know squats again very serious yep I
want you to concentrate I want you to
kick ass and I want you to first and
foremost know that you're my friends but
today you're the F in chain FMJ
the fun nasty grape leaf no guys what's
happened G you're the [ __ ] new guy
and it's never fun to be the [ __ ] new
guy are you ready yes are you ready yes
yes chef yes chef
so I'm not throwing you on the hotline
quite yet this is the most underrated
part this is meson Plus get familiar
place for everything and without having
meson bus every line cook will fail so
the scenario is our purveyors are late
you just got the shipment there's 15
minutes before service you have ten
minutes to patty out four ounce patties
great tomatoes that's the way I do it
and slice onions are you ready for this
yes chef one two three go
[Music]
they're [ __ ] ten minutes I got my
timer right here let's go yeah they need
to be four ounces good you're fine just
[ __ ] it the first one just right so I
can visually mash it just like that keep
going keep going let's just say that
this cost me $10 a pound you're out
you're off by five grams and each gram
is about I don't know ten cents if
you're messing up on 100 patties it cost
you $10 a day
yeah that's $3,650 thrown away every
year if you don't measure these things
right I'm not gonna cost you it done
that's what I'm talking about
all right let's stop you got me on your
board whoops I like to work like I'm a
factory machine right so instead of
pulling each onion one by one and then
peeling them all that's what I do
yeah four onions peel all four of them
and then just mow him down that's an
idea Nizam + Nizam + I'm gonna get a
tattoo of that actually that's pretty
good together
work done focus focus
guess I'll cut yourself on camera it's a
minute 52 seconds left and I need all of
these Tomatoes we're ready to go flat
hand that bad boy I don't want your
knuckles bleeding hurry leave it will
clean it after we'll clean it after 15
seconds I'm gonna be 2 tomatoes shot 10
9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
good I should pick up one of your balls
and it should weigh exactly 4 ounces you
can trust my balls yeah first the
walk-in and now just watch me next oh
you sons of [ __ ] sorry
yeah Wow I've got a lot of caffeine sir
one piece of advice I would give him is
to focus as much as possible and yes
chef
no chef I'm definitely a fan of babish
his basic series basically taught me how
to cook the custom did I hear you're
what Benjen babe it's Spanish here we
are the hot line the Thunderdome this is
the burger station I'm going to show you
how to do griddle cheese griddled burger
it's super simple and then we'll
increase it from there
ready yeah let's do it so obviously bun
down first shredded sharp cheddar and I
season it just a little whoa this guy
smashed on salts okay then you grab the
burger
and you're dragging you top of the
melted cheese like that my Almighty
that's right that size already cooked
yeah so our gold oh my god what do you
think gorgeous beautiful special special
sauce a little bit onion pickles that
should be done that is the thing of
beauty
dude right Wow out the door you got the
lesson got it
level up memorized order in special
smash burger do it I've been cutting the
tops really really short cuz it looks
like yeah you know you know you like to
have a big foundation on there
yeah good ratios you know that's so
that's what it's about well I got to get
my my butter game on point all right so
these go down you're already at peak
form looks like let's see if I can do
this there's a challenge press
oh you can feel it there you go
salt pepper and then that's straight
over you over here any cheese are you
this encouraging to do completely I am I
promise you I think yeah it's time
alright push it off Oh perfect there we
go alright that's it go right on no yeah
no you did wrong
well that was the stupidest thing
alright
good practice man you started off with
gust so what happened that was silly I
have such a good smashed before please
pepper pepper pepper indeed Oh all right
I'm gonna step it up one more time all
right all right get two more buns let's
cut it two more burgers are ordered in
alright
to birds yes chef yes sir
yes Father you know for all those times
your fans call you chef babish yeah I
gotta earn it you know this is where you
earned your stripes my friend Gordon did
it I did it
Emeril and will did it Bobby Flay here
we go that's okay here we go come on my
boys got it two more yes chef boom I'm
turning you into the most she gonna
shove the Chingo she gone
means you're a badass cabron means your
losses means you're a loser and your
wife is cheating on you oh bam bam
all right
sauce sauce let's get this guy rest how
about that
there you go now you're thinking looks
like they're beautiful
now grabbing our cheese of these guys
down you're a killing area now drop
decided to stop [ __ ] around also
everybody has to do at some point in
their lives sorry okay pickles onions
pics yep
last one alright later up
push her up chicken with my fingers on
the line with that bad boy
it's ready to go all right the Bell yeah
all right let's finish the seconds first
these guys up okay this guy's a little
loosey goosey here okay
came far a little bit yeah dude this is
your killer instinct right now your
focus you're hitting all cylinders all
right thank you
beautiful there now you go all the way
okay well now we go you you're getting a
rest there you go
[Applause]
[Music]
we're cheese it's just an all over
fitness or two more else what your focus
there we go that was a little that looks
gorgeous a little better hooked up for
me there you go there you go thanks Deb
wow it's crazy how your brain gets
scrambled oh yeah steak at the same time
think about it
burger one time up push them out and one
acceptable burger another one that
hopefully they don't notice you've made
it through the mock simulation you did
great tradition in my kitchen at the end
of each service that you know I got the
FNG I get to keep this a cup of water no
I think you're here you did a great job
look how great was that that was a lot
of fun dude you sure you haven't done
this before don't be nice like I killed
as many burgers as I made probably the
best-looking burger you threw in between
the so it's okay
yeah happens to the best of us this is
what happens in real life
everyone thinks it's easy right yeah
food just comes out of a window
only a [ __ ] thanks to this disease you
showed your chops thank you
you did you did a great job and I'm glad
that you that I was the first person you
did that with that was a lot of fun
awesome I'm glad to have you clean this
[ __ ] up yes chef
I give him a lot of props for even
stepping behind the line and dealing
with that kind of fire
I think Babbage did pretty good for a
rookie [ __ ] new guy
[Music]
what's up burger fam it's Alvin kai-lan
from the burger show
thank you for your continual support
make sure you hit that like button smash
that subscribe button
turn on your notifications if not for me
for the burgers
please and thank you